[dramatic music building]
REPORTER: This
small American group
includes a teacher,
a nurse, a recording
engineer, and a photographer.
10 years ago they might have
stuck to smoking marijuana.
But now they pass around
the lines on the mirror.
MAN: Save some for
the rest of us.
[laughter]
His structure is based
on two foundations.
One is extreme violence
and the other is business
and logistical organization.
His capacity for violence,
his ambition and his smarts
single him out.
And no one actually
ever challenges
Escobar's leadership.
Planes would leave the
jungle drug laboratories,
laden with cocaine,
and begin to fly
northwards and hopscotch
across the Caribbean
before it hit US shores.
CARLTON TURNER: And that
was all coming in to Miami.
So Miami was a
distribution point.
And Miami became a hotbed of
corruption, of the cartels.